he's Barry Zito former a baseball
pitcher three-time all-star monocyte
young won the World Series in 2012 and
has a new book called curveball how I
discovered true fulfillment after
chasing fortune in Fame available online
and wherever books are sold and Barry
joins us here in the New York City man
cave did you realize that it's been
about 15 years since I last crossed
paths I didn't understand I believe it
Spring Training 2004 was 15 years ago
that's scary yeah and I was doing a bull
pen session I was with Rob Dibble and
then you guys I think you said let's get
the radar gun let's see what you can
talk how dad and I went oh I'd rather
that I you know it was just like man I
think he was throwing pretty pretty hard
there instead of okay here's the jugs
gun and I think I topped out at 71 oh
yeah I was hoping you wouldn't throw it
on me I was happy about that
now did I throw harder than Jamie Moyer
did Oh Jamie that guy's an enigma he was
getting guys out with like 79 mile an
hour fastball how does that happen
it's mental witchery something but when
you throw a pitch like how many times
did you throw a pitch and go oh boy this
is bad oh yeah like you know well you
know as a pitcher people don't know this
but you the way that the ball feels off
your fingertips a lot of times you can
tell at that point
what's if it's gonna be a good pitch or
not even location wise I mean when that
timing hits up so you know sometimes
that changeup would come out of my hand
and I'd go no and of course it would be
a double in the gap or a home run or a
home run well they do you remember one
sound Greg Maddux would always tell me a
home run was like cars crashing like
there was just this sound and it's it's
unmistakable like did you ever have one
of those moments where it just stood out
where you went oh my god where is it
gonna land oh you know it's funny a lot
of guys when they give up a homer they
stare down the hitter right cuz they
know the second they see at the pitcher
yeah but why are you staring down the
hitter yeah like you know oh you it's
not he spoke he did what he's supposed
to do
yeah that's he's been working his whole
life to do that yeah yeah no I
I would always turn around and just hope
and pray that it wouldn't go over even
though I knew it was gonna be 30 rows
deep so I was the guy that turned around
oh no man who hit the longest home run
off you don't you like here you've done
all these here we go nobody cares about
what you did right we want to know what
you know no this is fun okay this is
gonna be totally out of the archives
Corey Koski in the Metrodome for those
of you that have been in the metrodome
in minnesota the old field this thing
was in the top deck literally in
right-center
so the third deck in the Metrodome was
nobody ever sat up there and they had
these big tarps yeah but he hit one in
the third deck in right-center it wasn't
down the line in the third deck Corey
Koski he had a bomb oh my that my ego
was crushed it
bring out Corey cos game yeah all right
let me let me go we were talking about
you okay first of all if you're just
listening on the radio and you don't
know what Barry Zito looks like you're a
handsome guy
you're like a WB actor like you'd be on
The WB somewhere that is the highest
compliment okay and then you decide to
play guitar like that's not really
unfair to the rest of us meit's ball
Hagen is what it does right that's good
you know
Alton I'll tell you why I started
playing guitar I mean I knew I was gonna
be on these bus trips nightmare I saw
Bull Durham like every other kid growing
up and so the second I signed with the
Oakland Athletics out of college I
started playing guitar cuz I knew I was
gonna be going nuts on these road trips
that's literally the only reason I did
it and did you take after anybody did
you model your your your you know guitar
playing after I think a lot of kids in
that generation were Dave Matthews
influenced I met Dave I have met Dave a
few times yeah you know he has no idea
who you are or what you did right no you
know what we had a this guy that used to
run a private jet company that I knew he
knew Dave and he introduced us you know
it's funny my wife was with me and she
walks by Dave and Dave makes a comment
about her and I'm like hey I'm over here
buddy and he looks at her and gives her
the up and down and I'm like okay I
guess whatever way I can get in right
you could have taken him yeah I could
have but Dave Matthews has no sports
knowledge whatsoever I don't think so no
no no I've been around him I was with
Darius Rucker yeah and he said hey just
so you know Dave is not going to know
anything about you and I
thinking are you kidding me of course he
knows you like me I mean I go backstage
and then I go hey and Darius goes hey
it's Dan Patrick and Dave Matthew spent
about three seconds maybe and he went oh
thanks to meet you then he goes right to
Darius and I go I'll be damned he has no
idea who I am
fast forward to I did a sandler movie
with him and I told him about that and
he goes and and I go well you like I
thought you would know sports he goes no
my drummer does Oh Carter huge fan yeah
but Dave had no idea whatsoever and that
funny yeah a lot of these creatives man
they're kind in their own little
laboratory you know doing that thing
what's bull how accurate was Bull Durham
oh that was the most accurate baseball
movie that there is that there ever was
what's your favorite story from the
minor leagues that you can tell my
favorite story was oh gosh first time I
ever signed
you know first basically my first couple
days in professional baseball I Drive up
to by say Lee California from my home in
LA a couple hours north and the the
catcher takes me out to the El
Presidente in Visalia was the hottest
bar in town proceeds to shove the most
cheap tequila in existence down my
throat and I show up to the field the
next day literally almost falling down
in the outfield because I just my body
had no water in it whatsoever and so I
asked my coach who was Curt young at the
time
Curt do you think I can go down to the
ER get a couple bags of saline because I
need some hydration and that was
literally my third day in pro ball so I
didn't not come out with a great
reputation in trouble I mean I was a
first rounder so maybe I got a little
more slack than the other guys but uh
that was the last time I ever did that
you know I hate Moneyball I do and you
don't own the story the portrayal which
part of it
well they don't mention the pitching
staff like you guys are an afterthought
in Moneyball in the movie like all it is
is about your these hitters who take a
lot of pitches like it's a it's the
Scott Hatteberg story you know yeah it's
it may not be super accurate
what happened I mean we also had an MVP
that year Miguel Tejada and they didn't
mention that either you know like
Moneyball it sounds in theory like oh
wow that's that's neat but in the
reality you had a great hitter and you
had a great staff you had a you know
great closer you can have Moneyball if
you have those things in blades right
yes no baseball team is going to perform
well without great pitching we know we
know that certainly in the playoffs and
you know the original script to that
film was actually more of the story that
was true to form but they thought it was
not going to sell well in the theaters
so the whole thing got canned and they
started over and they found a new rider
new director and everything so me me
Mulder and honey we're actually gonna
have cameos in the first version of that
movie and then you guys didn't get
anything yeah we never got gonna call
after that scraps is there gonna be a
sequel to Moneyball what when the sequel
be in Moneyball that would be
interesting oh man my mind's racing
everywhere right now you know it's funny
the a maybe a Jason Giambi story that
could be great
oh boy that could be good he was he was
now I love Jason I thought he was always
entertaining and wacky wacky Jason will
had an uncanny ability to show up to the
field with a couple big macs and fries
and then go like 3 for 4 with 2 bombs
but did you did you ever see the gold
thong did you ever I did see she wears a
thong he had an incredible tan as well
and and oddly no tan lines with the
phone so did you ever wear the thong I
never did no I was a young buck Jason
barely ever talked to me yeah he was a
huge leader in the clubhouse but he was
not like the rah-rah guy he kind of led
by example and he would let you know
when you were out of line but Jason
actually kept to himself quite a bit he
was pretty good I remember the homerun
Derby in Milwaukee Paul appalling and I
we we were with Giambi the night before
and he got plastered any Jason yeah go
figure
yeah and he was in a full sweat prior to
the homeland Derby like he was drinking
ginger ale and he goes I don't know if I
can go out there and they goes well
maybe I'll just go out there and then
I'll just you know pal out in the first
round and then he set the record in
first round of the homerun Derby oh that
is useful it was one of the more
incredible performances but I couldn't
tell anybody that he was hammered he was
still drunk I think during homerun Derby
oh that's so wonderful no you know what
listen there is something to performance
and when you're a little when you're not
totally crisp and you're a little tired
yeah I have heard some stories about
some great performances in the history
of the major leagues where the guys
actually were out most of the night
before and they came back and did these
historic things that we've all heard of
well David Wells did that yes David
Wells was one of them did you ever do it
that did not work for me really I may
have tried that once in the minor
leagues it didn't work so I was probably
too rested on my start days
the new book is called curve ball how I
discovered true fulfillment after
chasing fortune and fame available
online wherever books are sold we
mentioned yesterday you're sort of the
pitching version of Derek Jeter there's
I know you're happily married now but
there's friends there that you did well
you know here's my thing I was deeply
insecure good I was tonight I was
looking for something to validate me and
that's this book is kind of about the
idea that I didn't have a foundation of
anything that was more important than
baseball coming up I had a father that
was kind of a town he was a talent
manager and then I came along and I was
like his only client so he was you know
be famous go do this win championships
get all the money so I felt the
freshener you know yeah he had his own
fame aspirations he was actually a
conductor for Nat King Cole in his day
so he had you know he had his version of
Fame too and so when I started
performing poorly specifically you know
in San Francisco I started trying to win
songs in the Hollywood clubs because I
couldn't win him on the field anymore
so it was a really an overcompensation
thing the whole dating thing for me so
you lost your identity when you launched
your pitching ability absolutely
absolutely
yeah this book is kind of the very
transparent tale of a guy that took it
too seriously and the collapse
internally that happened as a result but
are you looking at these women these are
famous women but are you looking for
famous women to validate you in some way
in a lot of ways yeah I mean and my ego
was leading it was leading the charge so
you know I was seeing myself on the
cover of Us Weekly I was trying to be
like
okay red carpet this and that and you
know for me and I didn't it wasn't
conscious I wasn't like trying to use
these people for you know my own thing
it was this subtle motivation in the
background that was running my whole
life Alyssa Milano
who else Jennifer loved human my wife's
in the green room that's right I know
but your wife is you know what you're
lucky you found your wife I did is it in
the book Alyssa we use I use her name by
name and and the others are not and you
know but but who told you like at what
point does the light go off and say what
am i what am I doing here like Who am I
who told me that's a great question no
you know what my my pain and failure and
struggle told me I got left off that
roster after four years in San Francisco
and you know making almost 20 million
bucks to you know be a cheerleader and
then being so ruled by my ego I was
basically trying to survive so I ended
up rooting against the team as they were
trying to win a World Series you know
hoping they would lose to validate my
ego once again right I mean and so it
was a really dark place and so I go home
and all my friends are celebrating this
ring and I'm sitting there trying to act
happy in these champagne rooms but
really I'm like I'm a zero I'm making
more money in you guys and I'm actually
not even good enough to be a part of
this so that's when my whole thing just
came apart but what is that like that
you're making twenty million but you're
not really part of the team like are you
embarrassed
out embarrassed shame I mean the whole
deal you know I know people go oh woe is
Barry he's making twenty million but it
you know you're not thinking the money
it's just I'm not part of this team and
it you know it makes it even more
obvious that I'm making twenty million
then I'm not even good enough to pitch
oh yeah I mean I I would show up to the
field that thirty those thirty days I'd
show up to the field headphones
sunglasses I mean I had so much shame I
was walking in the tunnel to the
clubhouse and the concessionaires I felt
like we're giving me you know Scouts and
looking at me of course these guys are
busting their tails right making you
know not as much as we were and I'm
sitting here not even on the on the team
really and walking through the tunnel
trying to bow my head and you know don't
look at me man I mean I just I was
disgusted Wow hated myself
puff is that to go to the ball like you
must have hated going to the ballpark oh
the ballpark was the last place I wanted
to be the last place yeah I mean I would
literally drive around I remember
driving around San Francisco those days
before going to the park every day for
the playoff games listening to this
famous composer Japanese composer I
loved but he plays this kind of very
mellow piano music then just most the
time just crying in my own in my Range
Rover with the tinted window so nobody
could see me but like so just in the
darkest place why are you crying like
how did I get here like I came out of
the shoot like when in seong's and just
doing and what happened to my life you
know that kind of thing but there was no
injury mentally mental dl Wow yeah
mental deal yeah I didn't miss too many
starts but not many was a mess put on
the DL and it's listed as mental yeah
that's that was it I mean and for me it
all ties back to one thing I didn't have
a foundation of anything more important
than baseball right and so what happened
as a result I go back to LA going to a
12-step program for being obsessed with
opinions of other people's it's called
codependency step one I've become
obsessed with others opinions and my
life is becoming manageable and that was
it step two there's a power greater than
me that can restore my sanity I never
thought there was a Power greater than
me because of how I was raised and yes
spiritual background I thought I was the
higher power but you have to let
yourself go
you have to be willing to let yourself
go and that's really hard for a pitcher
who you're always in control every
fourth or fifth day you're in control
I'm on the mound and here you go
now I got to go okay take me wherever
you're gonna take me but somebody's got
to grab me oh that's it and there's so
much strength in that humility of this
is what I can control and everything
else is completely out that's actually
the biggest strength ever trying to
control every last detail
that's weakness and that's that's fear
right so I finally got to that point a
couple years later and you know good for
you and having a great woman there to
help you - Oh amber save me the book is
called curveball how I discovered true
fulfillment after chasing fortune and
fame Barry Zito is with us and when we
come back he'll bring out the guitar
ladies what are you gonna play I got a
couple songs once kind of like the book
thing though so I'll play that it's
called the secret to life okay is this
gonna be heavy yeah you got get the
tissues out you guys got maybe maybe we
do like a fun song hmm
can you do like a fun song I can do that
yeah we'll come back with berries you
know after this
she's very zito I can't say enough good
things about the book is it's a deep
dive curveball how I discovered true
fulfillment after chasing fortune and
fame available online wherever books are
sold not only win a siyoung win a World
Series all of those great things but he
plays guitar as well so he's gonna give
us a little medley here in the final
couple minutes of this hour so go go
ahead Barry let's do it all right it's
called the secret to life all right
ain't about the money that you got in
the bank
it ain't about how many hearts
you can break you don't matter how many
people know your name even though that's
what they say
[Music]
that's what they told me at least it
ain't about what place you get it in the
races that you run it ain't about the
big game that comes rolling off your
tongue her if you got good looks like
Elvis did when he was 21 even though it
is to son
[Music]
one thing I've learned from all these
damn mistakes mine
it's never worth the chase when she's in
temporary highs but I had to try yeah
the world's got a seat on top I saw it
once it wasn't what I thought I came
back down now I'm better off I mean I
know the secret to life but I know what
it's not how could you could you all
right where's the word the twine come
from that loss country twine where well
that's nice nice I don't know I've never
done that that's why I don't know
where'd the country twine come from you
know writing in Nashville you know a lot
of it a lot of the songs that you know I
had written for a few years after our
tire we're co-written cuz in Nashville
that's a thing you can write yeah and
you know and a lot of times my co-writer
would kind of sing it as we're writing
it and then all of a sudden I'm getting
a twang and it's like where'd that come
from I'm from San Diego I'm ever one
time we were playing the Rangers in
Arlington and I was at this bar ordering
a drink hey man can I get a beer and he
goes you're not from around here are you
I'm thinking yeah I'm Cali all the way
right he goes you're from North Texas
aren't you and I'm like he's like yeah
here you got the draw from North I don't
know where it came from
good for you yeah by the way thanks for
Gibson man I hooked it up with a guitar
yesterday on like two hours notice so oh
good this thing's awesome
all right hey good luck with the book
tour and life you know that more
importantly I appreciate it Dan yeah I
don't know if you care about our
opinions as you said you did before your
work about it our opinions but I always
always love talking to you because I got
something of substance when I spoke to
you I don't know who that berry was but
this berry it a pretty good person here
I appreciate that Dan I got some fun man
this is beautiful and it's nice to know
you guys well the book is called curve
ball how I discovered true fulfillment
after chasing fortune in Fame why wasn't
it fame and fortune why was it fortune
and fame it just sounded more a little
better real fortune and fame you know
fortunate Fame
you had to sing it it would sing better
it would as fortunately faint like and
why more with Fame right yeah you're
right yeah telling a reprint it's
available online wherever books are sold
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]